johnny depp ist sofort nach dem letzten
prozesstag am freitag geflüchtet und
nach england geflogen dort aufgetreten
am sonntag hat dort ein konzert gespielt
hat sich also abgesenkt von dem ganzen
drama und jetzt sehen wir hier amber
heard in das urteil der jury ist es
einstimmig ja
im zivilen fall cl 2009 10 29 11
ist der anspruch von herrn deb gegen
frau hält erster bezüglich der aussage
in der online meinungsbeitrag mit den
titel amber heard ich habe mich gegen
sexuelle gewalt ausgesprochen und habe
die gut unserer kultur gespürt das muss
sich ändern in der washington post
onlineausgabe zitat ich habe mich gegen
sexuelle gewalt ausgesprochen und habe
hier dann die wut der kultur zu spüren
gekriegt haben sie das gefühl dass alle
elemente der verleumdung nachgewiesen
von deutschland antwort ja hat herr deb
durch die beweislage überzeugend
dargestellt dass diese aussage getätigt
oder veröffentlicht wurde von frau hört
antwortete ja die frage
war diese aussage auf herrn deppe zogen
jahr war diese aussage falsch
war diese aussage eine verleumderische
aussagen über 100 antwort ja
die verleumderischen inhalte sind sie
darauf ausgerichtet gewesen von miss
hall tja
sind den entsprechenden umständen der
veröffentlichung nach eine
verleumderische implikation für jemanden
der dieses lesen durfte außer herrn depp
offensichtlich geworden antwort ja haben
sie den eindruck dass per deb durch
klare beweislage gezeigt hat dass
müssten gehört mit böswillige absicht
gehandelt hat antwort ja
2 bezüglich der aussage in
meinungsbeitrag mit dem titel ein
transformative augenblick für frauen in
der washington post hoc ausgabe und in
der online meinungslage
gehört ich habe mich gegen sexuelle
gewalt ausgesprochen und habe wie gut
unsere kultur zu führen gekriegt das
muss sich ändern in der washington line
ausgabe dort gab es das zitat und vor
zwei jahren bin ich dann eine
öffentliche figur geworden und habe den
köstlichen missbrauch dargestellt und
stand für ihn und habe die volle mut
unserer kultur gegen frauen zu spüren
bekommt die sich dagegen aussprechen
ende des zitats haben sie das gefühl
dass hier alle punkte der verordnung
erfüllt worden sind antwort ja hat hat
depp durch die beweislage darstellen
können dass diese aussage getätigt und
veröffentlicht wurde von frau hat
antwort ja frage diese aussage bezog
sich auf ein depp antwort ja
frage diese aussage war falsch antwort
ja
frage diese aussage hat eine
verleumderische applikation bezüglich
hand ab antwort ja
die frage diese verleumderische absicht
war beabsichtigt von frau hört antwort
ja
frage den umständen der veröffentlichung
dieser äußerung nach hat diese aussage
der firma torischen charakter gehabt
also verleumderischen charakterköpfe
menschen hat die nicht der depp born
antwort ja
haben sie
das gefühl oder sind sie der meinung
dass herr deb durch die beweislage
klargestellt hat dass frau hört mit
böswilliger absicht gehandelt hat
antwort ja
drittens bezüglich der aussage indem
meinungsbeitrag mit dem titel ein
transformative augenblick für frauen in
der moschee post druckausgabe und der
online meinungsbeitrag gehört ich habe
mich gegen sexuelle gewalt ausgesprochen
und habe die wut unserer kultur zu
spüren bekommt das muss sich ändern in
der online-ausgabe der washington post
zitat ich habe den seltenen blickwinkel
lehrer gehabt die in echtzeit sehen
können wie institutionen managt männer
schützen die des missbrauchs beschuldigt
werden haben sich hier den
das hemd ab alle elemente der
verleugnung nachweisen konnte antwort ja
hut ab durch die beweislage darstellen
können dass diese aussage getätigt oder
veröffentlicht wurde von frau hört
antwort die frage diese aussage und
äußeren bezog sich auf herrn depp
antwort ja frage diese aussage war
falsch antwort ja
frage diese aussage hat verleumderische
implikationen bezüglich herrn depp
antwort ja
fragen diese verleumderischen inhalte
sind von miss hört beabsichtigt gewesen
antwort ja frage aufgrund der umstände
der veröffentlichung dieser äußerungen
wurden verleumderische implikationen
vermittelt an menschen die dies gelesen
haben und die nicht herr depp waren
antwort ja haben sie den eindruck sind
sie der meinung dass herr deb durch
klare beweislage darstellen konnte dass
frau hört mit böser absicht gehandelt
hat antwort ja
gegen m gehört haben wir als jury ein
schadensersatz von 10 millionen dollar
verhängt gegen frau angehört haben wir
als jury dazu
strafzahlungen in höhe von fünf
millionen dollar beschlossen
im zivil- als cl 2009 10 21
ist die
anklage von frau hört gegen mister tab
bezüglich der auslage in der online
edition der achten machten april 2020
dass frau hört in den medien gehört
haben dass es
tatsächlich hier die verwendung von
sexuellen gewalt vorwürfen gab als
schild und als schwert benutzt wurden
und dass diese nicht wahr waren und dass
sie der öffentlichkeit mit mitgeteilt
wurden und auch gegen herrn depp in
anschlag gebracht worden sind haben sie
den fall folgendermaßen bewertet sind
hier alle verleumderischen aspekte
tatsächlich von frau überzeugend
dargestellt worden ein zweiter bezüglich
der aussage
der online edition der daily mail am 27
april 2020 vier ein zitat das war
einfach ein
angriffs war ein hoax also eine
vorgetäuschte tat wir haben die polizei
gerufen aber zuerst hat es nicht
funktioniert die polizeibeamten sind ins
penthouse gekommen haben dort alles
durchsucht haben ein interview
durchgeführt und sind dann nachdem sie
festgestellt haben dass es keinen
schaden an der person oder am eigentum
gab wieder abgezogen deswegen hat dann
frau amber heard wein verkippt und
einigen schaden angerichtet und hat dann
die geschichte ihren polizisten und
ihrem anwalt mitgeteilt und hat dann
einen zweiten anruf bei der polizei
getätigt ende des zitats haben sie den
eindruck dass frau hört hier alle
aspekte der verleugnung darstellen
konnte hat frau hört durch die
beweislage darlegen können dass frage
herr old men als agent für herrn deppe
diese aussage veröffentlicht hat ist die
antwort die frage ist diese
aussage bezog sich auf frau hört ja
diese
aussage wurde auch von anderen gesehen
als nur frau hört ja und diese aussage
war eine falsche antwort ja
sind sie der meinung dass frau hört
durch klare beweislage darlegen konnte
dass diese aussage von herrn goldmann
mit böser absicht getätigt wurde antwort
ja
drittens
bezüglich der aussage in der
online edition der daily mail am see und
20 april 2020 zitat wir haben den anfang
des endes mitbekommen des vorgetäuschten
missbrauchs durch ein depp von vorher
haben sie hier den eindruck dass frau
hört alle elemente der verleumdung klar
darlegen konnte nein die antwort der
jury gegen johnny depp dem zweiten haben
wir als jury
schadensersatzzahlung in höhe von
2.000.000 beschlossen gegen johnny depp
den zweiten haben wir als jury
schadensersatzzahlung beziehungsweise
schmerzensgeldzahlung ist höhe von 0
dollar verhängt
möchte eine der beiden seiten hier noch
etwas an die jury richten ja
ist dies ihr urteil jury dann sagen sie
ja
mitglied 15 ja
jurymitglied 16 jahre
jurymitglied 22 ja mitglied 27 jahre
mitglied 729 ja
ich habe also festgestellt dass das ein
einstimmiger entscheidung ist damit sind
sie aus dem jury dienst entlastet vielen
dank für ihre hingabe und für die arbeit
die sie geleistet haben während dieses
prozesses ich weiß dass ich für alle
sprechen wenn ich ihnen sage dass wir
die opfer die sie auf sich genommen
haben in diesem bereich ihrer
öffentlichen
dienste tatsächlich dass wir das alle
sehr zu schätzen wissen wir möchten sie
bitten sich noch einmal zurück zu ziehen
und dann werden sie vom kurierdienst
offiziell entbunden